.
Sairah sucht in ihrem Heimatland
Indien ihre leibliche Familie.
Trotz vielen Rückschlägen
hat sie noch nicht aufgegeben.
Der Stand meiner Suche ...
Also, ähm ...
... bei Null.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Ja.
Barbara Crole
musste im Zweiten Weltkrieg
als junges Mädchen flüchten.
Nach 75 Jahren reist sie zum
ersten Mal wieder zurück nach Polen,
in ihren Geburtsort Kolberg.
Irgendwie hat man immer noch
etwas Sehnsucht
nach dem Ort, wo man geboren wurde
und die Kindheit verbracht hat.
Jetzt komme ich und es ist fremd.
Auch Ando musste als Kind flüchten.
Damals hat er sein Heimatland
Armenien das letzte Mal gesehen.
Jetzt reist er gemeinsam
mit seiner Freundin Giada zurück.
Ein schönes Gefühl.
Ich komme noch nicht ganz klar.
Wahnsinnig.
Nach 23 Jahren
bin ich wieder zurück.
Das ist eine Reise
zurück zu den Wurzeln.
Die Reise in "Meine fremde Heimat".
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Sanfte Klänge *
Von Norddeutschland machen sie sich
auf den Weg zu Barbaras Geburtsort.
Diese Strecke fuhr Barbara
vor 75 Jahren schon einmal.
Einfach in die andere Richtung.
Damals hatte sie keine Ahnung,
wo es hingeht.
Es war kurz vor Ende
des Zweiten Weltkrieges.
Als Fünfjährige musste sie mit ihrer
Familie Hals über Kopf flüchten.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Damals konnte man nicht rausschauen,
da waren wir im Viehwagen.
Das ist schon ein Unterschied.
Und es hat ziemlich gestunken.
Und ...
Ich habe von der Strecke an sich
nichts gesehen.
Und die ...
Da hat einfach alles geschrien
und ...
... versucht ...
... zu sitzen und nicht zu stehen.
Die Babys haben in die Hose gemacht.
Es war absolutes Chaos.
Wir waren
eine relativ grosse Gruppe.
Die Sorge war immer,
zusammenzubleiben.
Keinen zu verlieren.
Wer gibt wem die Hand,
wer zerrt wen mit?
Was auch war:
Hört man die Flak?
Hört man Flieger, hört man Bomben?
Warum bleibt er jetzt wieder stehen?
Es war Chaos und Überleben.
Ich bin ein grosser Meister
im Verdrängen.
Markus nickt.
Äh ...
Das war auch deine Rettung.
- Ja, ja.
Dass du es von dir schieben kannst.
- Ja.
Es hat nicht existiert.
Zwischenstopp in Swinemünde.
Der Ort gehörte vor dem Krieg
noch zu Deutschland.
Später wurde die Stadt an der Ostsee
polnisch.
Von hier aus sind es rund 100 km
bis nach Kolberg,
wo Barbara geboren wurde.
Auf der Flucht kamen sie damals auch
in Swinemünde vorbei.
Deshalb machen Barbara und ihr Mann
hier heute Pause.
Gehen wir hier oder hier lang? Hier?
Alle Leute laufen hier entlang.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Tarifauskunft. Siehst du,
dort ist es polnisch angeschrieben.
Hier auch schon.
Bitte?
Es ist deutsch und polnisch
angeschrieben. - Ach so, ja.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Schau mal, Krolewskie.
Was heisst das? Ah, Crole.
* Beide lachen. *
* Unverständliche Kinderstimmen *
Ah, die reden ja polnisch.
- Ja, klar.
Es hat sich schon sehr verändert.
Was heisst denn das?
Dieses "poczta"?
"Poczta" ... Post!
Aha, ja, logisch.
* Perlende Klänge *
Sairah wurde als Dreijährige
von Schweizern adoptiert
und möchte in Kalkutta endlich
ihre leibliche Familie finden.
Bis jetzt ohne Erfolg.
Sairah und ihre Freundin Natalia
haben noch eine Hoffnung:
Sie gehen mit der Dolmetscherin
zu Michelle Harrison,
einer Therapeutin, die mit Waisen
und Adoptionsfällen arbeitet.
Would you like some? Yes, come.
You're welcome.
- Thank you.
* Sairah räuspert sich. *
Auf dem Bild
sehe ich nicht verhungert aus.
Ich trug auch gute Kleidung.
Ich habe mir Gedanken gemacht,
weshalb ich so gekleidet war,
als ich ins Heim kam.
Wer hat mich so gekleidet?
Wieso bin ich plötzlich im Heim?
Was vorher passiert ist,
weiss ich eben nicht.
Das ist für mich ein Rätsel,
das ich zu lösen versuche.
Sie hat mir
noch mal ganz deutlich gesagt,
dass ich mit der Suche
nach den Dokumenten ...
... hier in Indien
nicht mehr weiterkommen werde.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Michelles Worte sind für Sairah
eine grosse Enttäuschung.
Sie glaubte fest daran, auf
dieser Reise ihre Wurzeln zu finden.
Aber die Adoptionsunterlagen
scheinen verschollen zu sein.
Ohne die wird es sehr schwierig,
jemanden zu finden.
* Dumpfe Klänge *
Es gibt für nichts eine Garantie.
Auch wenn ich versuche, die Papiere
auf dem offiziellen Weg zu finden,
besteht die Chance nicht,
meine wahre Mutter zu finden.
Ja.
Das hat mich im ersten Moment
sehr mitgenommen.
Und worauf ist es für dich
nun beschränkt oder nicht?
Es ist der spirituelle Weg,
der mir jetzt durch den Kopf geht.
Jetzt geht es mir nahe ans Herz.
Ja, ich kann mir das vorstellen ...
Ich mache mir auch Gedanken.
Mich bewegt dieser Ruf,
den du vom Bruder spürst, immer.
Auch von der Mutter,
was du mir vorher erzählt hast.
Dass sie auch suchen
und Sehnsucht haben.
Wenn man dann auf dem amtlichen Weg
nicht mehr vorwärtskommt ...
Dann suchst du wieder.
Die beiden Frauen wollen
für ein paar Tage raus aus der Stadt,
um den Kopf zu lüften und sich
zu überlegen, wie es weitergeht.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Die letzte Etappe
in die fremde Heimat Polen
reisen Barbara und Markus
auf dem Schiff.
1945 flüchtete Barbara
mit ihrer Familie übers Wasser.
Ihr Geburtsort Kolberg wurde
von russischen und polnischen Truppen
umzingelt und beschossen.
Die Flucht
war nur übers Wasser möglich.
Heute lebt Barbara mit ihrem Mann
in Lausanne.
Seit 75 Jahren
war sie nicht mehr hier.
Das wäre jetzt unser ...
Ein bisschen kämmen
für den Kapitän.
Jawohl.
Sonst denkt er:
"Wie sehen denn die Schweizer aus?"
Merci!
Danke.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Grüss Gott.
- Das ist Markus.
Barbara.
Ich bin Konrad, herzlich willkommen.
- Konrad.
Heute ist das Meer ruhig,
und die zwei haben das Schiff
fast für sich alleine.
Kaum auf dem Wasser, sind die
Erinnerungen an die Flucht wieder da.
Barbara war damals fünf.
Das war eine Art grosser Kutter.
Wir standen alle an der Reling und
haben - Entschuldigung - gekotzt.
Dann gingen wir nach unten, und
dann hat man uns wieder rausgejagt.
Meine Erinnerungen
sind eher bruchstückhaft.
Das war alles so chaotisch,
diese Menschenmassen ...
In der Todesangst
vergessen Menschen ihren Anstand.
Also mein erster Gedanke ist:
Hoffentlich muss ich
auf dem Schiff nicht brechen.
Wenn ich das überwunden habe,
denke ich:
Haltung zeigen,
wie man bei mir sagte.
Äh ...
... also mir ist schon ...
... komisch ...
Die Fahrt auf dem Fischerboot
dauert ein paar Stunden.
Genug Zeit,
damit sich Barbara und Markus
auf das Ziel ihrer Reise
einstimmen können.
* Entspannte Klänge *
So, machen wir
den letzten Schritt noch.
Ja.
Wollen wir hier beim Tau?
Ich dachte,
hier kann man sich an den ...
Okay, wie du willst.
Ja, am Geländer auch.
Die beiden
sind seit 40 Jahren verheiratet.
In all der Zeit
hat es Barbara nie geschafft,
Markus ihre Vergangenheit zu zeigen.
Die Flucht aus der Heimat
hat sie bis heute nicht verarbeitet.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Ich habe sie jetzt absichtlich
alleine gelassen.
Es wird sehr schwierig für sie.
Das ist das erste Mal seit 1945,
dass sie wieder hierherkommt.
* Klappern *
Das ist ein anderes Land,
andere Leute, eine andere Sprache,
seit sie hier war.
Eigentlich ist es ihre Heimat,
sie wurde hier geboren.
Aber wahrscheinlich
ist es jetzt fremd für sie.
Aber das sehen wir dann,
wie sie reagiert.
* Der Schiffsmotor brummt. *
Kalkutta
ist die drittgrösste Stadt Indiens.
Nach ein paar Tagen
im Lärm und der Hektik
brauchen Sairah und Natalia
eine Pause.
Das haben wir gesehen,
als wir vom Flughafen kamen.
Das ist ein neuer Stil.
Die Verbindung dort
ist noch spannend. - Sehr.
Es hat kleine Fenster drin.
Es tut mir gut,
aus der Stadt zu kommen.
Meinen Kopf durchlüften.
Und auch mal wieder
zur Ruhe zu kommen.
Damit ich wieder
klare Gedanken fassen kann.
Sie fahren in die Sundarbans, die
grössten Mangrovenwälder der Welt.
Wie komme ich auf das Boot?
So, genau.
Ja, super.
Natalia und Sairah kennen sich
von der Arbeit im Pflegeheim.
Eine besondere Freundschaft, die
auf dieser Reise noch enger wurde.
* Indische Flötenklänge *
Ich empfinde es
als sehr bereichernd.
Ihre Geschichte
hat mich schon immer berührt.
Und berührt mich noch immer.
Die Vorstellung,
dass man vielleicht doch noch -
vielleicht auch eher zufällig -
jemanden aus ihrer Verwandtschaft
findet,
das begleitet mich
und ist in meinen Gedanken.
Wir haben schon einiges gesehen,
das uns eben so weit geführt hat.
* Indische Flötenklänge *
Was ist auf dieser Suche
noch möglich?
Diese Frage stellt sich Sairah
immer wieder.
Wir haben sehr viel versucht,
auch im Voraus
schon viele Ämter angefragt.
Und nirgends komme ich weiter.
Ja, das tut weh.
Aber die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Einen letzten Versuch
möchte Sairah noch wagen,
sobald sie wieder in Kalkutta ist.
* Sanfte Sitarklänge *
Zurück auf der Ostsee.
Am Horizont
taucht die Stadt Kolberg auf.
* Anschwellende Musik *
Links.
Als Barbara ihre Stadt
zum letzten Mal gesehen hat,
stand sie als Fünfjährige
auf einem Flüchtlingsboot.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Das ist die ...
... ich nenne es jetzt mal
Speicherstadt, das stand schon.
Aber ansonsten ...
... erinnere ich mich natürlich
nicht an viel.
Die 80-Jährige verliess damals
eine deutsche Stadt
und kommt heute
in eine polnische zurück.
Kommen Sie bitte.
- Sollen ... Ah! - Ja.
Danke.
- Bitte.
Danke!
Mein Wissen und meine Erinnerungen
an die Stadt sind recht begrenzt.
Ich frage mich,
ob ich das Haus wiedererkenne.
Und das kann ich nicht sagen.
Und ...
Womit ich Mühe habe
wo ich und mich frage,
wie ich reagiere,
ist, wenn sie polnisch reden
und ich Deutsch im Ohr habe.
Das muss ich sehen,
das kann ich noch nicht abschätzen.
Nimm bitte den Rucksack mit.
Wenn du zu mir sagst: "Kommst du?",
dann komme ich sofort.
Was macht das mit dir,
wenn du mit mir hier bist?
Das war vor meiner Zeit.
Du, das ist sehr schwierig.
Ich bin als
dein Herzallerliebster da.
Aber du hast selbst Gefühle.
Ja, für mich ist alles fremd.
Ich bin das erste Mal ...
Das hier ist mir auch etwas fremd,
aber ...
Ich bin jetzt gespannt,
wo du gewohnt hast.
Das interessiert mich.
Ja, was mich interessiert,
ist, wie weit die Vorstellungskraft,
nein, die Wirklichkeit
der Vorstellungskraft standhält.
Was habe ich mir eingebildet
und was entspricht der Realität?
Ist das ein mieses, kleines Haus?
Oder ist es das Haus,
das ich in Erinnerung habe?
Dann komme ich mit.
Es bleibt mir ja
nichts anderes übrig.
Ich danke dir.
* Möwen kreischen. *
Zurück in Kalkutta.
Sairah nimmt heute
einen letzten Anlauf
bei der Suche
nach ihrer leiblichen Familie.
Sie versucht es
auf dem spirituellen Weg.
In der Schweiz
war sie bei einem Medium,
das ihr einige Hinweise gegeben hat.
* Hupen *
Jö!
Here.
- Schön. - Ha!
Ich wollte Sairah einen schenken.
Symbolisch.
Ich wünsche ihr auf der Suche,
auf der spirituellen Suche,
ihren Schutz.
Dass sie sich richtig entscheidet
und das Richtige für sich auswählt.
Das war mir jetzt noch wichtig.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Das Medium sagte ihr,
sie solle an den Fluss gehen,
wenn sie in Kalkutta ist.
Dort drüben
hat es Stauden oder Bäume.
Ich müsste rübergehen, um sagen
zu können, wo genau sie sind.
Das Medium in der Schweiz sagte,
dass meine Verwandten, meine Wurzeln
auf der anderen Seite
dieser Eisenbrücke wohnen.
Langsam kribbelt es in mir.
*  Entspannte Klänge *
Beim Medium habe ich noch
eine Zeichnung gemacht,
als sie erzählt hat.
Das ist der Ganges.
Und ich müsse über die Eisenbrücke.
Von der wir gekommen sind.
Das ist die hier.
Dort auf der rechten Seite.
Dort wohnen meine Verwandten.
Sehe ich das richtig, der Ganges
fliesst in diese Richtung?
Nein, so.
- Dann müssten wir ... so?
Oder, nein,
der Ganges fliesst dort runter.
Es ist etwas oberhalb.
Sie sagte, bei der Eisenbrücke,
es müsste dort oben sein.
Das Heim ist dort unten.
Das Kinderheim.
Sie sagte,
dass meine Verwandten etwas
ausserhalb von Kalkutta wohnen.
Also dann gehen wir hier runter
und unten durch.
Und dann schauen wir.
- Mhm.
* Hupen *
Dieser Turm dort kommt dir
überhaupt nicht bekannt vor?
Nein.
Ich stehe ihr zur Seite,
obwohl ich mit diesem Medium
nie Kontakt aufgenommen hätte.
Das ist nicht meine Welt.
Aber mir liegt sehr viel daran,
dass Sairah auf ihrem spirituellen
Weg eine Begleitung hat.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass
meine Verwandten wirklich hier sind.
Ich bin nicht mehr nervös.
Dann bin ich wahrscheinlich
nervöser als du. - Ja.
Ich bin sehr gespannt,
was jetzt passiert.
Es ist interessant:
Ich schaue in die Gesichter der
Leute und schaue, wer ihr gleicht.
Wer ist es?
Ich wünsche es dir so sehr.
Ich wünsche dir so sehr,
dass wir endlich einen Anhaltspunkt
finden, der uns weiterführt.
Ja.
- Eine Bestätigung.
Die Bestätigung wäre z.B.,
die Getreidefelder zu finden.
Hier in dieser Umgebung,
das wäre meine Bestätigung.
* Indische Sitarklänge *
Ob Sairah ihre Familie findet,
hängt von vielen Faktoren ab.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir
sie heute nicht sehen werden.
Nur schon das Wetter.
Ich sehe ein sonniges Bild in mir.
Heller Sonnenschein,
und jetzt ist es dunstig.
Auch wenn die Bilder nicht stimmen,
fahren die beiden noch ein paar
Kilometer weiter an den Stadtrand.
* Vogelschrei *
* Stimmungsvolle Musik *
Barbara macht die ersten Schritte
durch ihren Heimatort Kolberg.
Sie möchte möglichst schnell
zu ihrem Elternhaus und schauen,
ob es noch steht.
Der Weg führt am Strand entlang,
an dem sie früher immer spielte.
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
Es ist so anders.
- Ja, ja.
Früher war es ein Naturstrand,
jetzt ist es ein Kunststrand.
Und Betonstrand.
Vorne wurde noch
etwas Sand aufgeschüttet. - Ja.
Kolberg ist heute ein bei Polen
und Deutschen beliebter Touristenort.
Jedes Jahr kommen Hunderttausende
hierher, um Ferien zu machen.
Das macht mich ganz betroffen.
Und ...
Das ist nicht mehr meine Heimat.
Irgendwo hat man doch immer noch
einen Rest ...
... Sehnsucht
nach seinem Geburtsort,
an dem man die Kindheit verbrachte.
Die hatte ich immer.
Wie schön es war, der Strand.
Jetzt bin ich hier,
und es ist fremd.
An den Weg zu ihrem Elternhaus
erinnert sich Barbara,
als ob es gestern gewesen wäre.
Wir sind immer alleine,
ohne Aufsicht, zum Strand gegangen.
Und ...
... ich habe im Gedächtnis,
dass es einfach geradeaus geht.
Ich weiss nicht mehr, ob das stimmt.
Ich weiss auch nicht, ob das Haus
durch ein grösseres ersetzt wurde.
Ich bereite mich jetzt
seelisch darauf vor.
Dass der Strand nicht mehr das ist,
was er war,
das finde ich traurig.
Aber na ja, Strand ist Strand.
Das Elternhaus kann man nicht
so ersetzen wie den Strand.
Deswegen ist es mir
jetzt willkommener,
das Haus als den Strand zu sehen.
Also jetzt krampft sich
mein Magen zusammen.
Sairah sucht am Stadtrand
die Hinweise des Mediums.
Schau,
dort vorne hat es grüne Felder.
Ja, es hat ziemlich grüne Felder.
Schauen wir mal.
- Ja, schauen wir nach.
Jö, Küken.
Es kommt mir etwas fremd vor.
Erinnert dich gar nichts
an deine Vorstellung? - Nein.
Was es sein könnte?
- Nein.
* Stimmengewirr *
Also Wasser hätte es hier genügend.
Jetzt bin ich sehr verunsichert.
Jetzt brauche ich etwas,
das mir wieder Halt gibt.
Jetzt fühle ich mich sehr unsicher.
Es wird auf jeden Fall gut,
das weiss ich.
Das kommt gut.
Es ist schwierig.
Aber Glauben ist auch wichtig.
Aber das muss ich dir nicht sagen,
das machst du.
Du glaubst so fest daran,
dass das passiert.
Und ich glaube eigentlich auch,
dass du diesen Platz einmal findest.
Ja.
Die Sonne.
- Jetzt verschwindet sie wieder.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Barbara ist mit Markus
auf dem Weg zu ihrem Elternhaus,
das sie im Zweiten Weltkrieg
fluchtartig verlassen hat.
Du weisst, wo meine Hand ist,
wenn du sie brauchst.
* Sie lachen. *
Nach 75 Jahren
stellt sie sich ihrer Vergangenheit.
Aha.
Dann muss das jetzt die ...
... Neun sein.
Siehst du?
Völlig anonymisiert.
Ich hatte auch den Eindruck,
dass der Eingang vorne war.
Da ging man die Stufen nach oben.
Man ging hier rein durch den Garten.
Und dieser Erker,
oder wie man das nennt,
war dort mit dem Balkon.
Guten Tag,
sprechen Sie deutsch?
Ich heisse Barbara Crole,
ich wohne in der Schweiz.
Schweizer, ja?
Das ist mein Mann.
Aber ich wurde hier geboren.
In diesem Haus.
- Wo? Hier?
Wieso ist das alles nummeriert?
Hier erkenne ich gar nichts mehr.
Ähm ...
Aber es wurde nicht zerbombt.
Es ist eines der wenigen.
Früher wohnte Barbaras Familie
alleine in diesem Haus.
Heute hat es
viele kleine Wohnungen darin.
Ich glaube,
jeder möchte
seine Kindheit und Jugend wieder ...
... seine Kindheit wieder finden,
die so brutal zu Ende ging.
Ich dachte,
wenn ich wieder im Haus bin,
kann ich wieder
an die Jahre anknüpfen,
die ich verloren habe.
Es ist keine Heimat mehr,
es ist nur noch fremd.
Das ist nicht mehr mein Geburtshaus,
das ist ...
... nichts mehr,
ein anonymes Reihenhaus.
Das war es.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Das Kapitel ist jetzt abgeschlossen.
* Sie spricht französisch. *
Während Barbara ihre Heimat
für immer fremd bleibt,
hat Sairah in Indien immer noch etwas
Hoffnung, etwas Vertrautes zu finden.
Unterdessen beginnt in Wettingen
eine neue Reise.
Die des 30-jährigen Ando.
* Fröhliche Klänge *
Ich wurde hier geboren.
In Jerewan wurde ich geboren.
Und aufgewachsen?
Aufgewachsen bin ich zwischen
Jerewan und der Nähe von Aparan.
Auf der Karte sieht es nahe aus,
aber als wir früher ...
Das und noch viel mehr möchte Ando
seiner Freundin Giada zeigen.
Morgen fliegen sie
zusammen nach Armenien.
Die Grossmutter mütterlicherseits
lebt noch dort.
Wenn ich zum ersten Mal
eine armenische Karte vor mir habe
und ich sehe, wie weit es von Jere-
wan nach Aparan tatsächlich ist ...
Es ist schön, das so zu sehen.
Macht Freude.
In der Nähe von Aparan. Ich
muss schauen, wo genau Aparan ...
Ando war sieben,
als seine Familie von Armenien
in die Schweiz flüchtete.
Seither war er nie mehr
in seiner Heimat.
Jetzt habe ich die Möglichkeit,
zurückzukehren.
Es nach 23, 24 Jahren
wieder zu sehen,
das ist für mich
die grösste Motivation.
Für mich ist Armenien fremd.
Ich bin zum ersten Mal
auf dieser Seite der Welt.
Ich höre ab und zu Dinge von Ando,
dass die Landschaft sehr schön
und das Essen gut ist,
die Leute sehr nett sind,
davor habe ich keine Angst.
Aber das mit der Sprache
wird problematisch.
Meine Motivation
war immer meine Herkunft.
Wieso habe ich mich beim Boxen
so durchgebissen?
Ich habe nie vergessen,
woher ich komme.
Ando hat das Boxen
zu seinem Beruf gemacht.
Als Profi trainiert er
mehrere Stunden am Tag.
Boxen bedeutet mir alles.
Ohne Boxen wäre ich verloren.
Das Boxen hat mir
sehr viel Rückhalt gegeben.
Sehr viel Selbstvertrauen.
Es hat aus mir
einen anderen Menschen gemacht.
* Rocksong: "Out of the Black"
von Royal Blood *
Ich bin ursprünglich aus Armenien,
lebe aber seit 20 Jahren
in der Schweiz.
Ich wurde in Jerewan, Armenien
geboren.
Ich bin halb Schweizer,
halb Armenier.
* Rockige Gitarrenklänge *
1996 flog ich mit der Familie
von Jerewan nach Weissrussland.
Von dort mit dem Fluchtauto
nach Polen,
von Polen nach Deutschland,
von Deutschland nach Frankreich,
von Frankreich nach Spanien.
Mit viel Glück sind wir dann
in der Schweiz gelandet.
Die Odyssee durch Europa
dauerte fast drei Jahre.
Aus dem Flüchtlingsjungen von damals
wurde ein erfolgreicher Sportler.
Ando ist u.a. Schweizer Meister
im Superleichtgewicht
und auch im Ausland erfolgreich.
Für den Traum des Profiboxers
gab der 30-Jährige alles.
Seine Familie hatte kein Verständnis
für seine Leidenschaft.
Heute hat Ando keinen Kontakt mehr
zu seiner Mutter
und seinen beiden Brüdern.
* Rasende,
sich steigernde Elektromusik *
Sie haben nicht an mich
und meine Träume geglaubt.
Böse gesagt
haben sie mich fallen lassen.
Für mich ist das Thema beendet.
Giada und Ando
sind seit fünf Jahren zusammen.
In ihrer Familie fand er einen Ort,
an dem er sich zu Hause fühlt.
Das sieht gut aus.
- Das hast du sicher gern.
Sehr gerne.
Ando, hast du Hunger?
- Boah. - Also, anfangen.
Ich habe so hart trainiert,
ich muss etwas essen.
Wie viel möchtest du?
- Zwei, drei. - Eins.
Los.
Giada hat noch zwei Geschwister.
Für ihren Vater
gehört Ando zur Familie.
Er ist mein vierter Sohn.
Ja, der vierte Sohn.
Ich liebe ihn, seit ich ihn
das erste Mal gesehen habe.
Ich dachte,
dass er sicher ein lieber Mann ist.
Das war mein ...
Ja, er ist auch ein Lieber.
Für mich ist es keine Ersatzfamilie,
es ist meine Familie.
Ich bin ihnen sehr dankbar, dass sie
eine so tolle Tochter haben.
In erster Linie
muss ich ihnen Danke sagen,
dass ich Giada an meiner Seite habe.
Du Romantiker.
Schöne Worte hast du gesagt.
- Guten Appetit. - Danke.
Giada und Ando haben schon
zusammen Ferien gemacht,
aber so weit gereist
sind sie noch nie.
Giadas Mutter
macht sich etwas Sorgen.
Es ist das erste Mal,
dass sie weggeht.
Und dann so eine lange Reise.
In ein anderes Land.
Aber ich denke, dass es gut kommt.
Wenn sie mit Ando zusammen ist,
ist sie in guten Händen.
Der Flug nach Armenien dauert 6 Std.
Das Land liegt im Kaukasus
neben Georgien, Aserbaidschan,
der Türkei und dem Iran.
* Folkloristische Klänge *
Am Flughafen der Hauptstadt Jerewan
wird Ando erwartet.
Von seinem Cousin und seinem Onkel.
Nach 23 Jahren landet Ando zum ersten
Mal wieder in seiner alten Heimat.
* Sie sprechen armenisch. *
Ich konnte es gar nicht glauben.
Jetzt sehe ich meinen Cousin,
aus ihm ist ein Bär geworden.
Eine richtige Maschine
ist er geworden.
Das freut mich sehr.
Und er ist Judo-Meister,
und ...
Das freut mich jetzt sehr.
Ich muss das erst realisieren.
Die Leute hier ... das ist etwas ...
... ein schönes Gefühl.
Ich komme noch nicht ganz klar,
wahnsinnig.
Nach 23 Jahren
bin ich wieder zurück, sehr schön.
* Folkloristische Klänge *
Nächste Woche
bei "Meine fremde Heimat":
Ando wird bewusst,
wie sehr ihm Armenien
in all den Jahren fehlte.
Nach so langer Zeit
wieder hier zu sein, ist schön.
Und Sairah sucht in Indien
weiter nach ihren Wurzeln.
Ich habe sehr viel Neues erfahren,
bei dem ich gemerkt habe,
dass ich jetzt Zeit brauche,
um alles zu verarbeiten.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Michaela Hoss - 2020